Jude Law no longer has a ride to the
after parties if anyone's interested
here are the nominees for achievement in
film editing
Andrew Weiss bloom Black Swan Pamela
Martin the fighter tareeq anwar the
King's Speech Angus Wald and Kirk Baxter
the social network Jon Harris 127 hours
and the Oscar goes to
Angus Paul and Kirk Baxter to the social
network
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for angus wall and
kirk baxter their first nomination came
in this category for the Curious Case of
Benjamin Button I'll get up first things
first
um we want to thank everybody that Aron
thanked first and foremost um and a
special thank you to David who it's
indescribable working with you and thank
you for starting my career 20 odd years
ago also big thank you to our wives who
allow us to have incredibly passionate
love affairs with our families and our
work to my daughter Bronte find
something you truly love doing and great
things can happen the hard part is you
got to meet someone like Fincher cheers
and thanks very much to the Academy
you
[Music]